James Madison writes in Federalist 51  that men are not angels their passions  and self-interest often get the better  of their reason and sense of justice so  we need government in order to protect  our rights against those who would take  them away but for the same reason  Madison writes government must be  limited because people in government  have passions and interests too many  Americans today forget this supposing  that we can do away with constitutional  limits on government supposing that the  unelected bureaucrats being put in  charge of our health care for example  will rule as if they are angels if  Madison was correct however it will  become clear that they are humans not  angels learn more about the Constitution  a constitution minute calm